the pop singer lizzo twerks about
self-love in front of a giant inflatable
butt at the MTV Video Music Awards we
examine how the cult of self-love can
actually lead to self hatred then future
also-ran bado O'Rourke gives the slave
owners answer on abortion at a campaign
event at the College of Charleston and a
man leaves his wife for freshman
congressman and socialist squad member
Ilhan Omar when pressed for comment
representative Omar brushed off the
allegations stating oh please he's like
a brother to me all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
I can't take credit for that Omar a joke
much as I would like to that one is
going around Twitter yesterday and I
first saw it on the account Bhoomi leaks
which has the handle not woky leaks so
i'ma follow that's a pretty good joke
there's a lot to get to today a lot of
weird sex going on if we have time we'll
even get to some updates in the Jeffrey
Epstein story but I have to begin with
the Video Music Awards did you watch it
no you didn't because nobody really
watched it but there was some seriously
culturally relevant stuff going on it
wasn't good it wasn't pretty it wasn't
true and it wasn't beautiful but it
tells you a lot about the culture that
you are in a singer who I had never
heard of or seen before but now I'm like
downloading all of her stuff because
she's so fascinating is Liz Oh Liz Oh
stole the show at the VMAs by twerking
in front of a giant inflatable but the
the VMAs are very very stupid and they
pretty much always have been and they
don't matter at all in themselves and
especially this one because it was the
lowest rated VMAs ever they got one
point nine three million viewers I mean
we have several YouTube videos that have
many more views than that so that that's
not what we're talking about the reason
that it matters though they're actually
two reasons why this matter and it tells
you something about the state of culture
right now the first reason for why this
matters is it shows just how far our
culture has fallen so for those of you
who aren't watching this there's this
singer and she's a voluptuous lady so
that this is important to the whole
story of the song she's a more
full-bodied performer trying to be
polite about this and then a bunch of
other singers come out or dancers and
they go and they start dancing around
and then behind them is this huge like
two or three story tall inflatable butt
and that's the our culture which
produced Bach which produced Chopin
Mozart which produced Gregorian chant
our culture which built this
teen chapel which sculpted David by
Michelangelo which sculpted the Pieta
the Duomo the cathedral Chartres the the
Cathedral of Notre Dom that culture has
now decided to reward as its high point
of the year a giant inflatable butt and
a woman rattling off gibberish well
other women come on stage and just shake
around this is unfortunate for the
culture and because it used to be it's
not like we never had low culture before
we've had fart jokes and comedies for as
long as there have been comedies for
thousands of years but there's also been
a high culture and the low culture has
told us something about the high culture
and the high culture has built these
cathedrals and written these symphonies
there is no high culture anymore it
doesn't exist it's no this is the high
culture which is the low culture which
is a giant inflatable but so then lizzo
gets into the dance she calls these
girls on stage and what you can't quite
tell when they first come on but you
quickly learn is that the girls in their
costumes are wearing assless chaps and
then Liz oak continues to speak in this
sort of slang and then the girls twerk
in the assless chaps for the nation this
shows the contradiction of the sexual
revolution in a particularly hilarious
way again I would point you to the giant
inflatable butt and the contradiction
here is that on the one hand feminists
tell us feminists tell women in
particular that dressing nicely and
putting on lipstick and wearing a dress
is horribly oppressive and it is
degrading because it objectifies women
makes women into sexual objects that's
on the one hand on the other hand we are
told that going on national television
in assless chaps and twerking in front
of a giant inflatable butt is empowering
because it gives women's sexual agency
some of us knew that feminism was alive
from the very beginning some people
didn't realise that I think now we're
finally seeing I think now we're finally
seeing that live we were told that
gender studies for instance was an
important step in empowering women now
we're seeing the gender studies is
erasing the whole category of women
altogether through gender etiology the
left is very good at destroying things
the left is very good at deconstructing
the left is very good breaking things
down the left is very good at
criticizing they are so good at pointing
out all the flaws and weaknesses and bad
aspects of culture everything that was
wrong with the way that women behaved
and were treated in the 1950s and 60s
the left is really good at pointing that
out there excellent pointing that out
but the left's trick is that we never
hold them to account for proposing an
alternative they say it's terrible that
women are staying at home and raising
children it's awful that they cook
dinner it's terrible that they wear
dresses and wear lipstick and do their
hair degrading objectifying how terrible
they can't do that here's your assless
chaps ma'am please put those on that way
you can be empowered does anybody
seriously believe that these women
dancing on stage are respected more than
a 1960s housewife does anybody really
believe that these women that women
generally are made better off today by
casual sex and a culture demands that
they get a job in a culture that
discourages marriage and a culture that
discourages men from taking
responsibility for their actions nobody
seriously believes that that is
ridiculous
but then we get to the second reason
that Liz's twerk evm a performance
really matters for the culture it is a
subject that has come to dominate not
just leftist culture but even some
people on the right and it is absolute
poison we'll get to what that is in a
second but first let's get down to
business
and let's talk about one of my favorite
companies vistaprint your next big
opportunity is coming right now and all
it takes to feel like you are ready to
own the now is $10 because I go to a lot
of events right and I very often would
forget to bring business cards and this
is a huge faux pas business cards you
don't need to spend a whole lot of money
you don't need to hire a designer you
don't need to go to some specialty store
this
prynt can give you 500 personalized
cards with exactly the look you want for
just 10 bucks and then you have them and
then you look like an adult and not like
an irresponsible child who doesn't even
have his contact information so you make
a an introduction to somebody that could
change your life could be a great
business opportunity could be a great
personal opportunity and what are you
gonna do you're gonna write your number
down on a cocktail napkin or something
not a good look 10 bucks for 500
personalized business cards is a low
price to make a lasting impression and
because you can choose the colors fonts
designs images that means that you can
create something as unique and
compelling as your business I've been
involved in a lot of start-up businesses
for years and years now I have always
used vistaprint I've always been so
thrilled with their services going back
to 2010 2011 I've been using them
consistently almost every year since
then they're just terrific if you needed
any more reasons to choose vistaprint
you can feel good knowing that mr. Brent
uses only carefully selected inks and
responsibly sourced paper stocks so
you're getting top quality satisfaction
100% guaranteed or your money back they
will make it right but you won't need to
get your money back because they do a
great job vistaprint wants you to own
the now in any situation so they're
giving you 500 high quality custom
business cards starting at $9.99 go to
vistaprint.com slash Moleskine to wles
vistaprint.com slash Knolls get 500
custom business cards own the now valid
offer only through September 8th so go
right now
vistaprint.com slash knowles so on the
one hand you see how the culture has
just been totally destroyed integrated
you go from Bach to lizzo to working but
the the more urgent reason I mean look
we could complain about the culture
decaying all day the more urgent reason
why this VMA performance matters is
because lizzo is singing about self-love
self-love has totally taken over our
culture it is not just in music it's not
just in TV it's the biggest trend in
publishing self-help books are like the
dominant category of books and they have
been for decades on the left and on the
right and in the center and in people
that are not political at all it's all
about self-help self
love self self self it's certainly the
biggest trend in social justice circles
if you read any left-wing website you'll
see that there are all of these pushes
towards self-love it's so hard to love
yourself right before she walks up and
gives this speech she says I got a
bottle of tequila and she drinks I mean
it's I assume it's water but she
ostensibly drinks an entire bottle of
tequila which is loving herself and then
she gets up and talks about loving
yourself and maybe it was accidental or
maybe she's just a good artist and she
understands the symmetry there but
that's what self-love is self-love is
like drinking yourself into a stupor
makes you feel good for a little bit and
ultimately it leaves you with a bad
hangover unless you totally depressed it
leaves you totally empty to quote Homer
Simpson alcohol is the source of and the
solution to all of life's problems maybe
you got to reverse that and it's the
same thing with self-love you got to get
up you got to love yourself it's so hard
to love yourself she's talking to a
roomful of celebrities she's talking to
a roomful of extraordinarily privileged
and wealthy people even the ones who are
in celebrities have just gotten to go
there they've flown out to wherever the
MTV Video Music Awards are they bought
an expensive ticket and they're dancing
around with a ton of celebrities and
just all they're doing is indulging
their own pleasures and their own
desires it shouldn't be hard to feel
good in this society and what what
aspect of the society is telling you not
to love yourself we have the most
indulgent society probably in the
history of the world and our most
rigorous universities we've taken away
academic rigor we now have safe spaces I
mean no joke there are kids at elite
universities in this country who are
given little private rooms with crayons
and puppy dogs if their candidate
doesn't win an election that they want
them to well really if they're leftist
candidate doesn't win the election I
don't think conservatives get the safe
spaces is this a totally indulgent
culture the whole code the whole moral
scheme of the culture is if it feels
good do it you do you love yourself
and so this theme is absurd on its face
and I think I don't know if you've ever
heard of Liz oh I had not heard of Liz
Oh before and so coming into this
without any frame of reference I think
gives you a certain Claire
because you think oh my gosh what has
been going on well I've been looking
away from the video music worse how did
we get to this place and lizzo makes her
point what is the premise of self-love
how did we get to this point the premise
of self-love is you deserve everything
you want she's saying you deserve to
feel good as hell you deserve it you
deserve to feel good as hell that's a
lie you don't not only do you not
deserve to feel good as hell but nobody
feels good as hell all the time people
feel good as hell like some of the time
that's a fantasy that's a delusion the
culture of self-love is a lie who are
these people trying to convince you know
if you got to go out there and say I'm
really beautiful I'm really beautiful
I'm the most beautiful thing in the
world you probably don't believe it
right
I forget who wrote about this it was one
of you know I just kind of default as CS
Lewis but it was one of those types of
guys said that I think was CS Lewis
actually said that the really
intelligent guy doesn't have to talk
about how intelligent he is to the
stupid guy it's always the stupid guy
talking about how intelligent he is to
the intelligent guy
it's never the good-looking person who
says I'm really physically attractive to
the ugly person but it is the ugly
person who says I'm really physically
attractive to the good-looking person
because they're just trying to convince
you you're not confident in you have
this sort of insecurity this is never
more true than with self-love the people
I see most on social media or who write
in magazines and journals who posts the
most about self-love are the most
miserable people I know to a man or more
often to a woman this is always true I
like there there is almost no exception
to this rule if you are constantly
prattling on about self-love
you don't love yourself you're just
trying to convince other people that you
do and you're trying to convince them to
go down this rabbit hole of madness
called the self-love culture and it the
reason that they don't love themselves
is not because they're failing at
self-love I think that's the ideas if I
don't love myself if I don't feel good
hell all the time then I'm not just not
loving myself enough I need to think
about myself more I need to think about
how I'm entitled to more things and then
I'll be happy no the opposite is true
you won't be that's the prop the self
love is the problem you usually almost
always the people who talk about self
love all the time or loving themselves
they are behaving in a selfish way
they're behaving in a self-centered way
they're always talking about themselves
they are absorbed in themselves but a
man wrapped up in himself makes a very
small package indeed it's just
selfishness it's just self-centeredness
that make you miserable that's the
problem you think that selfishness and
self-centeredness are going to make you
really happy and feel good as hell
that's what the culture tells you they
don't they always make you miserable we
used to know this this used to be common
sense but common sense is no longer
common in a culture that exalts twerking
in front of a giant inflatable but this
common sense has been beaten out of us
now if you say that you're perfect the
way that you are if you say if you think
you deserve all the happiness in the
world the culture tells you that's
exactly the right thing actually you are
giving yourself a recipe for misery
guaranteed the culture of self love is a
culture of delusion and entitlement so
what is the actual beginning of real
love not self love but actual love first
of all it's not self-centered that love
is on someone else you you might hear
this from a certain Jewish fella who
walked around Israel 2,000 years ago who
said love the Lord your God and love
your neighbor as yourself love the Lord
your God what your loving your maker
that you're loving with gratitude you
are loving the person who gave you this
wonderful life that you have and then
you who are made in the image of God
love your neighbors as yourselves and
you do unto others as you would have
them do unto you the actual beginning of
real love is this humility and this
gratitude it's a love of other first of
God and then because of that of your
neighbor and
what is your love of God your love of
God expresses a gratitude for the life
that God gave you which you did not
create you are an even if you're an
atheist even if you're an agnostic even
if you have some other religion we can
at least agree you you are not
responsible for your life you did not
create your life you were born into this
world and you were not responsible for
that and you're gonna live and you're
gonna do a lot of things and then you're
gonna be taken out of this world most
likely you're gonna have no say in that
either your life at a fundamental level
is not your own you have a you can
express a gratitude for that and that
realization that you're not responsible
for coming into this world you're
probably not gonna be responsible for
coming out of it is cause for a humility
st. Agustin I think it was who said the
four most important virtues are humility
humility humility and humility the that
culture that actual culture of real love
not self-love would be Lizza
getting on stage in a sort of nice
elegant dress and then thanking all of
her fans for listening to her music she
goes for the Video Music Awards and she
says hey this is lovely thank you so
much for listening to my music and
making me popular and I really like that
and I really like all of you it would be
lizzo reminding everyone who's in that
room who's dancing around to the fun
tunes how lucky they are how
unbelievably privileged they are to be
able to be in that room listening to fun
music that they like and to be in the
greatest country in the world that's
that allows them to do that gives them
so much freedom so much prosperities
such a good protection of their rights
and how lucky they are just to live just
to be alive what a time to be alive that
would be a culture of real love by the
way that's what award shows used to be
until like five minutes ago
award shows used well not five minutes
ago really started going downhill in the
70s but before that the award shows
where you would get up there and you say
thank you so much thank you thank you to
my country I'm so glad to live in the
greatest country on earth and thank you
to God for blessing me with all these
wonderful blessings good night that
exhibited something called class that
exhibited something called grace that
was rooted in a fundamental
humility then award shows became about
entitlement you saw this a little bit
when brando went up at the oscars he
didn't go to the oscars he sent a Native
American Indian to complain and that was
when things started to turn a little bit
for the worse then you saw Michael Morey
he goes up at the Oscars and he
complains and now people just go
complain they get up there and they say
everything's terrible Trump's awful and
all the people who voted for him were
terrible and everyone it's all BS it's
all BS I'm tired of the BS I need to
love myself more people need to love me
more feel good let's all feel good it's
not nice people don't like that you
don't have to take my word for it back
in the olden times you know like 20
years ago people were happier and 40
years ago people were happier and 50
years ago people were even happier still
this is according to every survey that
has attempted to measure happiness and
satisfaction now it's difficult to
measure those things because in many
ways they're unquantifiable but in so
much as they are quantifiable people
used to be a lot happier and by the way
the objects of this sexual revolution
and the particular objects of this
culture of self love and the
participants largely in this culture of
self love are women and they have become
the most unhappy their happiness is
dropped off most precipitously both in
absolute terms and in relative terms to
men this culture is poison now what do
we have we have rising epidemics of
misery loneliness drug addiction and
suicide not even just among older people
but among teenagers as well
surging rates of teenage suicide up 70%
in recent years obviously something
isn't working
obviously the culture of self love
so-called is not working you know
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over and over again and expecting
different results so maybe and we've
tried this self love entitlement I I get
mine self love culture for a long time
maybe let's try something else maybe
let's try humility or even modesty and
modesty and humility are related but
they're not the same thing modesty would
imply for instance some gratitude and
fewer inflatable
it's inflatable butts are not modest
assless chaps are not modest and I don't
think they make anybody happy speaking
of this culture of shallow selfishness
though we've got to get to someone who
is a far greater embarrassment to our
country than Liz oh and wizards fans I
speak of course of beta or orc beta or
orc taking the culture of selfishness
and shallowness to the campaign trail he
was at a campaign stop at the College of
Charleston because he still thinks he's
running for president even though he's
polling at negative 7% or something like
that he still thinks he's running is
still out there he was asked a question
about abortion there's an amazing
question the guy said I was born I don't
think was September 8th was you know
whatever year he was born on September
7th was I not a human being entitled to
live should I have it should it be okay
to murder me on September 7th a day
before I'm born and beta or ork gives a
gruesome answer a grotesque answer a
cruel and enormous answer but he gives
the honest answer I was born September 8
1989 and I want to know if you think on
September 7th 1981 89 my life had no
value
of course I don't think that and of
course I'm glad that you're here
but you you stop it right there you
heard that but that's the but that's
gonna negate everything he said no of
course I don't think you should have
been killed the day before you're born
and of course I'm happy you're here but
and he's gonna go on to negate
everything that he just said because I
say this is an honest answer that he's
about to give because the logic of
abortion is if it's okay to kill a
person it's okay to kill a baby at I
don't know two weeks old then it's okay
to kill a baby at four weeks old and
it's okay to kill a baby at 40 weeks old
the logic of abortion is either you
can't kill innocent humans ever or you
can kill them at some arbitrary line and
if if the line is being drawn at Birth
if it's all about pre birth and post
birth and of course you can kill the
baby a day before he's born and and
really if you're following that to its
logical conclusion you can kill the baby
after it's been born as the Virginia
Governor Ralph Northam talked about said
yeah if the baby's born but the mother
wanted to kill it then we'll put it on
the table we'll make it comfortable and
then I'll ask the mother if the mother
still wants to kill it
and if she does then we'll kill it I
mean that was the implication of what he
was saying so better work says no no of
course you were a dignified human being
the day that you before you were born
but reference my answer in in Ohio and
it remains the same this is a decision
that neither you nor I nor the United
States government should be making
that's a decision for the woman to make
[Music]
what does that even mean
so I oppose murder
I think murder is wrong and we shouldn't
murder people they don't work says I
agree yeah no yeah sure I get it you
don't want to be murdered
it would be bad for you to be murdered
but that's a decision for the murderer
to make not for you to make that's you
know actually even let's take this
argument further the answer that he is
giving is the slave owners answer
because the the if you try to talk about
it it's just a matter of law and and
loss about murder it doesn't make any
sense of course we have laws against
murder we have laws against littering we
have laws against killing the spotted
eagle of course we can and of course
it's a matter for the government
that's what democratic politics is
that's what Republican politics is is us
deciding as a people what laws we want
to make what kind of country we want to
live in then we elect people to pass
those laws and then we live under those
laws so of course that's a matter for
the government if the question of life
and death is not a matter for the
government then what is littering okay
the government can handle littering but
on questions of actually protecting your
life the government has to stay out
unless it's the life of the spotted
eagle or the delta smelt or any other
person except for the babies when it's
convenient for us to say that we should
kill them that doesn't make any sense
the the more coherent argument that he's
talking about and it's coincidental that
he's giving this at the College of
Charleston is about is really about
slavery that's the argument the argument
he's making is look regardless of what
you think about slavery that's not a
decision that the government can make
that's that's a decision for the
slaveholders look you you might not have
you might not support slavery so you
don't have to have any slaves but the
slave owners got slaves you you're gonna
tell him that he can just release his
slaves have how dare you how could you
come and tell him to do that the slave
owner as a slaves you don't have your
slaves that's fine agree to disagree
it's choice he chooses to have slaves
you choose not to have slaves and the
obvious answer to that is what about the
slaves choice isn't the slave a person
what about the babies choice isn't the
baby a person it's not a matter just for
the mother to decide the baby's a baby
it's unbeliev you know that it's he's
not quite making an argument for states
rights he's even going more radical than
that he's making an argument for slave
holder rights is making an argument for
murderer rights doesn't make any sense
it's so utterly cowardly it is so
profound
immoral and I mean bait over work is not
going to be remembered in history but
for the significant people who are
making this argument they are going to
look so so bad
in future eras if there is a future era
of moral clarity they're gonna look just
absolutely awful they are defending
pretty much the worst thing you can
imagine just killing innocent little
babies will get to where bado even draws
out further the slavery analogy and then
we will get to
Ilhan amorous sex scandal I can't
believe if I'm saying that but you know
hey we're in silly season are we will
get to all of that maybe some updates on
Jeffrey Epstein if we have the time but
first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube you know daily wire
is turning 4 years old so still old
enough to abort I think in Virginia and
in the state of New York but but you
know getting around that age now where
it's really pretty a significant thing
for years thank you to all of our fans
as a thank you we are giving away one
month of our premium monthly
subscription to anyone who uses the code
birthday so ease it go go over use the
code birthday get a whole free month
subscription for all of August as we
celebrate this milestone we've been
giving away free first month for new
premium monthly subscribers
just use the code birthday time is
quickly running out there are only three
days left to get in on this deal so
subscribe today come on and join the fun
go to daily wire com we'll be right back
with a lot more
okay so the government has no say in
whether or not we kill babies bado goes
on with his argument the best possible
access to care into a medical provider
and I'll tell you the consequence of
this this attack on woman's right to
choose and and and and I listed to you
and I hurt your question I'm answering
it and the attack on on Roe versus Wade
which we thought was the settled law of
the land and unless we had any illusion
that the achievements that we've made
are protected forever or that progress
is inevitable that has been shattered
right now I don't want to tell you some
of the consequences of this okay we
thought the Dred Scott was the settled
law of the land okay we thought that the
Supreme Court's decision in Dred Scott
that blacks can never be citizens we
thought that was the settled law of the
land that's a Supreme Court decision
okay and now now we're being told it's
not slave owners rights to choose or
being challenged and then you see the
guy there the guy who asked the question
he's like right but what about my right
to live what what about guy I you
telling me you could kill me a day
before I was born okay I listen to your
argument okay now listen to my argument
okay Dred Scott is the settled law of
the land okay and slave owners have a
right to choose now check out this this
sick move on my skateboard check this
out
I can do it well I eat a french fry so
he you see starts the argument talking
about women's health care now he'll get
back to that this is another minefield
for him but the argument this is the
settle what we've had a lot of bad
settled laws in this country and we
overturned them because they're horrific
they're enormous
they're not tolerable he won't
acknowledge that then he gets into an
even worse decision for him right now an
even worse area of the argument which is
women's health care in my home state of
Texas thanks to these trap laws that
make it harder for providers to offer
the full spectrum of reproductive care
more than a quarter of our family
planning clinics have closed
and it has made us one of the epicenters
of this maternal mortality crisis
because not only can you not get safe
legal access to an abortion you cannot
get access to a cervical cancer
screening or a family planning provider
or in a state that refused to expand
Medicaid any provider at all and we're
losing the lives of women in our state
as a result okay now he's just sort of
rambling because he knows he can't
answer this question because his answer
is so morally repugnant but what he's
starting to get at is the shrinking of
so-called family planning services
because of different rules and
regulations one rule for instance just
came out this past week out of title 10
which was the federal government trump
administration came in and said okay we
are going to continue to give out the
quarter billion dollars a year of title
10 funding title 10 funding is for
family planning services but we're not
going to give that money out to
abortionists so you can either have your
title 10 funding your family planning
funding if you actually want to be a
family planning provider and not a
family killing provider right you're
actually planning growing families they
call it reproductive health it's the
exact opposite of reproductive health
it's against reproduction and it kills
you so it's obviously not health they
say okay well give you the reproductive
health we'll give you the family
planning but you can't provide abortions
so you can either have your family
planning or you can have abortions but
you can't have both and all of these
leftist organizations that pretend to
focus on family planning turned away the
money why because they have nothing to
do with family planning and all they
want to do is kill babies Planned
Parenthood gets 60 million dollars a
year through title 10 funding and they
turned it down now they get a lot of
other they probably get another what 440
million dollars of taxpayer funding at
least every year through other programs
so they still took well over a 10% hit
because they don't actually do family
planning they just kill babies
that's what bado is talking about here
and what the Republican response to that
should be is well we want to help women
we want to help families we want to help
mothers here's all the money we're not
we're not going to cut one penny from
any of that funding
you have to choose abortion or women's
health because abort because what the
left has done is conflate abortion with
women's health but they're not the same
so what the right can do is make the
left choose we should do it with a more
serious candidate than bata our work
these bado
ain't going nowhere and then he finishes
up his pseudo argument I don't question
the decisions that a woman makes I mean
only she knows what she knows and I want
to trust her with that so I appreciate
the question I don't question a decision
a woman makes what kind of patronizing
idiocy is that because women can't make
mistakes just like women can't lie you
have to believe all women because women
can't lie they don't make mistakes they
don't lie this is I mean not at the
height of the Victorian era did people
treat women with such ridiculous
unreality with as put them on such a
pedestal
Wow they can't lie goodness great can't
make any mistakes why would you trust
women more than you would trust men when
they would trust anybody if a woman
wants to kill somebody it's just as
wrong as if a man wants to kill somebody
if a mother wants to kill her child it's
just as wrong as if a father wants to
kill his child doesn't make any sense
speaking of other very bad Democrats
though I want to move on to one who's
more relevant than poor mr. beytagh and
that of course is Ilhan Omar Ilhan Omar
is now caught in a sex scandal
Ilhan Omar if you thought she couldn't
get bad enough she stole another woman's
husband this just came out out of
divorce proceedings that are going on in
court there's a woman a physician who's
55 years old she's married to a 38 year
old man who is a political consultant
and a Democrat that consultant has
worked for left-wing Democrats in his
career including Ilhan Omar he also
worked for keith ellison so he works for
all these radicals the 38 year old man
democrat operative in the 55 year old
physician have a 13 year old son
together now he is going to leave her
and break up the marriage because he's
fallen in love with Ilhan Omar this from
the court papers the
Arty's physically separated on or about
April 7th 2019 when defendant told
plaintiff that he was romantically
involved with and in love with another
woman
Ilhan Omar it gets even more sorted
because not only did the congresswoman
Ilhan Omar steal the guy's their the the
woman's husband she also paid this guy
his name is Tim my net and his
consulting firm two hundred and thirty
thousand dollars through her campaign
since 2018 so it's something like one
out of every three dollars she's spent
or something like that has gone to this
guy's campaign or this guy's firm the
reason I bring this up it's awful when a
spouse leaves and a marriage breaks up
it's just awful I know many people who
have found themselves in that position
if I can offer any consolation consider
this at least your spouse didn't leave
you for ill huh no more so you know
every storm cloud has a silver lining
it's bad enough to say honey I am
breaking up our marriage and I'm leaving
you for someone else but imagine if you
heard honey I'm breaking up our marriage
and I'm leaving you for the devil yes
yes the actual devil
I love the devil I'm leaving you for
someone who giggles when she says al
Qaeda someone who compares the United
States military to terrorists I am
leaving you honey
I'm leaving you for the devil a little
silver lining I I'm actually not even
mentioning this to pick on Ilhan Omar
I'm not surprised by this I don't i
politicians are not exactly known for
their marital fidelity now in part this
is a temptation of the office because
there you're getting adulation all the
time and you've got long hours on the
road and long hours away from your
family so there's a kind of natural
temptation there there's also the
personal temptation of the kinds of
people who run for elected office the
kinds of people who run for office in
Washington you know some of those people
are really good honorable men like
George Washington most often they're
just vacuous egotists who have a huge
ego and do whatever they want and a lot
of them are sociopaths anyway so
I'm not even looking sociopath I don't
know probably she giggles about al-qaeda
and she breaks up some poor woman's
marriage so yeah it seems like in the
sociopath corner there a lot of letters
a lot of evidence and in the not
sociopaths corner there isn't but I
mentioned this in particular because
Ilhan Omar is the left's vision of
purity she is she wears all white I mean
she even wears all white right shirt I
am the pure I'm ideologically pure I'm
religiously pure cuz the left hates
Christianity and I love all other
religions that aren't Christianity and
Ilhan Omar is a Muslim they love that
they like that she hates America she's
just so she's so virtuous compared to
Trump how awful Trump said that she
should go back where she came from
she's wonderful she's more American than
Trump she's so wonder she's perfect
Trump should go back where he came from
that's what they say she's sort of the
anti-trump and now we find out that
forget even ideologically because the
right doesn't like what el ha no more
thinks reasonable people don't like what
L hanno Mar thinks and the left doesn't
like what Donald Trump thinks so just
forget ideologically for a second from a
personal level
Ilhan omar is just as debauched as
Donald Trump we've heard for years Trump
is so terribly debauched on a personal
level he's been married three times
he's slept with his friends wives who
say he's cheated on whatever Ilhan Omar
is at least as personally debauched as
Donald Trump and guess what I suspect
most of the people in Washington are
pretty personally debauched because
they're people and it's a corrupt place
and they're often vacuous egotist and
they're getting a lot of adulation
they're away from their families just
pointing it out for the left next time
you throw stones
speaking of adultery next time you throw
stones consider what you are doing
consider what your side looks like
before you pull the speck of dirt out of
your neighbors eye your opponent's eye
maybe pull the plank out of your own
I've got to get to a little bit of
Epstein because there's some serious
Epstein stuff going on over here Jeffrey
Epstein is somehow still in the news
Washington Post is reporting the footage
from the cameras stationed outside of
Epstein cell during the time that he
allegedly committed suicide is
apparently unusable are you kidding me
to recap this is what the people want us
to believe this is what the people
investigating this whole situation want
us to believe the guy with the worst
dirt on the most powerful people in the
world just committed suicide well maybe
he did he was under a lot of pressure
and he was going to jail for a bad crime
okay except he was taken off of suicide
watch just six days after he allegedly
committed tried to commit suicide in the
first place taken off of suicide watch
whoops what a mistake then his cell mate
was transferred out who could have
stopped it or even witnessed it then
both of the guards who were supposed to
be watching him on the night he
committed suicide
both just happened to fall asleep at
exactly the same time and they left him
alone for hours and hours then an
autopsy showed that he had a bone broken
in his neck that is very rarely broken
in hanging even if you're hanging
dropping off a stool and actually
cracking your neck
much less leaning forward on a bunk bed
it's much more common in strangulation
but okay let's just don't call it let's
still call it suicide then there were no
cameras pointed inside his cell and now
the camera pointed to the outside of his
cell wasn't working what does that even
mean what does it mean the footage was
unusable does it mean that there was a
tech glitch does it mean someone
switched it off or does it mean someone
put a sheet over it I don't know all of
this as more evidence emerges from a
2005 raid on Epstein's compound which
found under naked underage girls photos
of naked underage girls and phone
messages from very powerful people
couple phone calls from Trump a couple a
couple now actually the Trump ones are
at least he has an excuse which is that
at exactly this time he alleges that he
and Epstein had a falling-out over a
real estate deal whether or not the
phone calls were about the real estate
deal I don't know but at least he has
this one excuse other guys don't even
have one excuse George Mitchell Democrat
senator phone calls from him phone calls
from Harvey Weinstein and lots of
messages from underage women asking if
they could come over and give him
massages it would be literally
impossible to arrest and question all
the powerful guys associated with
Epstein you got two presidents you got a
prince you got senators you got foreign
dignitaries a lot of powerful people
what about ghyslain Maxwell why is
ghyslain Maxwell not been arrested the
madam who is procuring girls and
allegedly abusing them with Epstein why
is she still walking around free that
doesn't make a lot of sense so if the
government wants to put conspiracy
theories quote-unquote to rest that
Epstein wasn't just accidentally
permitted to kill himself and maybe
something else was going on they at
least need to bring in Maxwell if
nothing further comes from this case
then the story that he was simply
accidentally permitted to commit suicide
is just not credible one quick story I
got to get to before we go you remember
a few months ago the College Board
announced an adversity score for test
takers so you're gonna take the test and
then you were gonna be scored on your
adversity there was outrage because that
was ridiculous so yesterday they
announced they're dropping the adversity
score that's great conservatives rejoice
except the College Board is lying they
did scrap the adversity score but they
launched a new version called the
landscape program which is the exact
same thing as the adversity score the
University score was one score on the
students suffering the landscape program
gives you six scores about the
neighborhood you grew up in in the high
school you went to media have family
income in that neighborhood all that
sort of stuff this is a terrible idea
and it's very dishonest they're saying
they got rid of it and they didn't now
instead of one adversity score you get
six the problem isn't the number of
adversity scores the problem is the
concept of adversity scores in the first
place there is no such thing
you cannot quantify suffering you can't
do it I know poor kids who grew up in
bad neighborhoods and they had a much
better upbringing than rich kids who
grew up in rich neighborhoods I know
kids who grew up in great loving homes
in poor neighborhoods and I know kids
who grew up in really really rich homes
where the father beat the mother
regularly in good neighborhoods you
can't quantify suffering everybody
suffers that is a fact of life and it is
marxist claptrap to pretend that
suffering can be boiled down to economic
conditions that just is not the case
suffering is not primarily a factor of
your economic circumstances or your
financial circumstances actually usually
suffering is a factor of spiritual
circumstances and
chants the rain falls on the just and
the unjust alike and by turning a
disadvantage into an advantage you are
perverting a culture that should center
around humility and gratitude and you're
turning it into one that incentivizes
self-pity and entitlement that is a very
bad thing it's a very bad lesson to
teach kids also the entire purpose of
the SAT is to standardize a test the
minute you bring in these completely
fungible or completely malleable
subjective adversity scores you
completely undermine the entire purpose
of the SAT there is nothing
compassionate about that there is
nothing right headed about that is the
worst lesson to teach kids as they go
into college which don't forget campuses
are the future look at a college campus
that's the country you're gonna get in
20 years and if we have an epidemic of
self pitying so-called self love now
which really leads to self-hatred just
imagine how bad it is going to get when
we try to measure suffering itself we so
incentivize that even before the kids
make it to college not a good look for
the future of the country
hopefully they change it that's our show
come back tomorrow get your mailbag
questions then in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show see them
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Danny D'Amico our audio mixer is
Mike Cora Meena hair and makeup by
Jesuit Elvira production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Nolt show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 on the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation